[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Ubiquitous computing,
or the internet of
things, is all about
having technology
wherever and whenever
that you might want or need it.
And that's so that we,
as users, can focus more
on what we're doing and less
on how to start doing it.
That could be anywhere;
it could be on your wrist,
in the living room, in your
car-- anywhere and everywhere
that makes sense.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
For developers, this
means thinking less
about developing an app
and more about solving a
user's problem, whatever
they happen to be doing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And the trick here
is that there's new
paradigms for all of this.
It's not just about sitting
down at a desk with a keyboard
anymore.
How can we use speech, gestures,
context, and glanceable UIs
to make an effortless experience
for the user, whomever
they happen to be.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: It used
to be that you needed
to build your own
hardware, libraries,
and infrastructure to build
these kinds of experiences
for your users.
But now, the Google platform
provides a ton of functionality
so that you can build these
experiences without having
to reinvent the wheel.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In our DevBytes,
blog posts, communities,
and design sprints we're
addressing these key issues,
so you have all the tools you
need to navigate the space
and get the most out
of your integration
with the Google platform.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
look for more videos
on Android Wear, Google Cast,
Android TV, Android Auto,
and more on the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
Great experiences on Android
TV are casual, cinematic,
and simple.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In
a cinematic app,
the interface should fade
away, putting content front
and center.